can you break down can you give us like
a Reader's Digest version of all how all
that happened okay yeah break down so
okay 2008 we start writing the the
screenplay rocker decision you know at
that point I invested my own money
I hired a screenwriter and gave him the
parameters I said this is the story I
want to tell and you know as an
independent filmmaker it's really
important that when you're working with
this with a screenwriter you you let
them know the parameters because if the
screenwriter comes back and says okay
opening scene you know spaceship lands
and you know alien comes out and blast
somebody with a laser rifle you're like
okay well there's your whole budget the
film and the opening scene so you're
done so so I just told this creature out
of the parameters I said look pal this
is this is this is the reality of it
we're going to shoot here we're going to
shoot here we're going to shoot there
this is the story I kind of want to tell
give me a screenplay that that's going
to work for that so once the screenplay
was done and that was my own personal
investment so I had skin in the game so
that was key that's point number one if
you want to make a film you got to put
something into it you got to put some
personal sacrifice has to go into it
because if you go to a finance or
without personal sacrifice and without
being professional no one's going to
really think you're legitimate
especially if you don't have any
connections so you know point number one
is be professional and and you need to
take risk on your own project that's
critical it's easy to play around with
somebody else's money very easy and a
lot of people in this industry do and
and they're not professional in my
opinion so be professional put some skin
in the game and then then see if you can
get the financing we happen to be able
to get 80% of financing from
non-traditional investors and once we
had that financing we shot the film we
were very realistic on our talk or
target audience at that point which was
going to be a foreign category I didn't
feel like as a first-time filmmaker I
would have a chance of competing here in
Hollywood I figured I needed to find a
way that I could make a film that would
be appreciated abroad and my strategy
was a little
friend in retrospect maybe I would have
just done more of a Hollywood centric
film but I chose to do a film that would
be more world friendly not you know not
heavy on the sex you know not heavy on
the violence and the swearing but still
compelling still in action action drama
film and you know once we we
accomplished that film the I guess the
the readers didn't I just point to would
be when you're when you're distributing
your film you got to be involved in
every step otherwise you're going to get
what's the word ripped off so yeah
they're your money's going to go into
somebody else's pocket so with
especially with foreign distribution you
have to be involved with everything you
have to know what theaters the films the
film is being played and you have to
know how much money that theater is
making so it's it's once again a
logistical nightmare because for you to
keep track of the funds of a film so you
can actually make a profit off of it is
it's crazy a lot of times I hear you
know filmmakers say oh well we have a
distributor and it just read the film
for us but it didn't make any money and
my question is well how come it didn't
make any money how do you know what well
they told us in hidden so that you have
to have full transparency with your
distributors and if you don't you're
going to get taken for a ride so these
guys who say like hey you know we have
the strategy we're going to give you a
report every quarter unless they're
fully transparent either sell it
outright but don't go for a percentage
so that's the big big point for
filmmakers out there don't do it
telling you right now don't do it
because it's your you're gonna end up
with the short end of the stick stick so
you know we got the funding and we made
made a profit by choosing to focus on
foreign foreign sales at that point and
that we you know moved on to the black
rush and the black question came about
because there was actually a couple
theaters in the north of India that were
playing to film for over a year so I was
really interested in
trying to figure out like well why would
anybody want to want to play my film for
over a year because I was you know I'm
I'm pragmatic I'm a realist I'm like
well you know I thought that's weird I
found that very strange so I took a trip
to go up into this part of India to find
this theatre which the film is still
playing like it's like a cult favorite
now like well why is this cult favorite
what is about the people here that
appreciate the film and I thought I
could learn something like maybe I could
learn something you know by watching
these people that so that way I could
emulate that in the next film but
extrapolate that to a larger audience on
my journey there is when I encountered a
lot of you know problems which I saw
with the drug trafficking in India and
that's where the concept of the Black
Russian came about the current film so I
was investigating aqua decision when
they the whole impetus and idea of the
Black Russian occurred and then when I
got back the United States I we started
the screenplay for that and I knew where
to put the money now as opposed to just
sitting on it
you